pour terminer ce journal un petit cadeau
de noël et une histoire sans parole
yauba grégoire patrick voix et
jean-jacques le garrec sont allés jeter
un coup d'oeil sur l'une des avenues les
plus chères du monde avenue montaigne
on s'y prépare comme ailleurs à noël et
même si ce n'est pas forcément
accessible
cela reste beau à regarder à quelques
jours du réveillon
la vitrine des poupées barbie ou ya 300
ans en poupe et donc c'est tout animé
par fouzia deux fils par couple saison 6
ans filles se sentent lésés médecin
quand certains un kilomètre et demi du
sud 2011 installé dans la vitrine
alors ensuite dans fédéraux cycle et le
chariot qui courent autour ils font
paris nice a des retours pendant le vol
en décembre
e
là
à
le thème de les rois mages et aux
mensonges du symbole j'ai deux enfants
des cadeaux des deux côtés fabuleux des
vêtements de ces rois qui sont venus de
très loin pour apporter à chacun c'est
une activité dont on ne voit pas les la
crèche voilà
et
et voilà